what's up everybody I hope you enjoyed
today's matchup appreciate anytime fan
love comes it's just remarkable and so
he's fun to give exposure to people that
are putting out the work I also love the
topic of controlling what you can
control the enormous Delta I seen the
marketplace is most people just well
about things they can't control instead
of focusing on what they can and I think
this does an extremely good job
explaining that do you know yourself or
do you aspire to be something you might
actually not be you have the freedom but
you have to execute it I'm just gonna
take your time because these are 15
you're gonna make it up and try to front
which is your vulnerability or you'll
just put in the work put in the work put
in the work and that's it like it's just
a process man like this long like you
know like we are just completely in this
incredible place of unlimited options I
just struggle with people's inability to
have perspective on where they sit an
opportunity in a 7 point 7 billion
person world the quickest and easiest
way to get to do what you want while
paying your bills is to start
sacrificing leisure and other things and
start focusing on monetizing the thing
that you want to do in the future I used
to drag through school by the time we
got to 3:30 I was like dead because I
hate it so you can't put in the hours
unless you love it you that's why I
believe loving it leads to the most
success because I think somebody else
loves what you don't love that you're
doing for money thus they'll be more
successful because they're gonna do 419
out now there's talent yeah you may not
love singing and you open up your mouth
and you sound like Whitney Houston
that's real you may not love that
there's athletes absolutely know them
who are not passionate about their sport
but they were born six foot ten
and very coordinated so it happens it
happens but I think that's the rarity
you're ranked amongst the seven point
seven billion people in the world when
it comes to opportunity is ridiculous to
have a special life you have to do
special things and that usually means
putting in the work and loving it
you take your advantages some advantages
are experience some advantages are used
the blood reaches it's not gonna happen
overnight in a half years before you
better get to dream
please factor in what the world's going
to be like in 2019 to 2025 versus
looking at what the world was like 2009
to 2015
way too many decisions by way too many
people are being made in the by
factoring in the past without
anticipating the future forget about
Benzes and shoes and homes and planes
the ROI of life is not money it's being
happy and when I look at the people that
I see that are happy regardless of their
income levels or success or fame or
notoriety or money so much of that is
completely predicated on the fact that
either their parenting or circumstance
help them have actual perspective to
what the hell is going on in here do you
know what I wish for all of you 25 year
olds in here that you knew how young you
feel at 40 News Alert you're gonna kind
of feel exactly the same I don't think
there's anything wrong with chasing
money I just think that it's usually the
quickest way not to get it I am
remarkably stunned by the lack of
accountability in our society everything
wrong at vaynermedia anything that ever
happens any piece of content anything
that ever happens in my life 100% is my
fault
and let me tell you what happens with
accountability you get real happy when
you feel that there's no other source
controlling you're all of a sudden it
gets happier your ego and your
insecurity doesn't want to take the L
you don't want to admit that you've done
because for some reason so many of you
are living your lives based on other
people's opinions and that is crippling
you the way to really eliminate fear is
by not giving about anybody's opinion my
losses are mine I'll deal with them
myself
I don't need your two cents you're
losing plenty on your own patience and
inner voice makes you unbeatable this
phone is more powerful technology wise
than the computers that Ronald Reagan
had to run the free world this thing
while you lay in bed from 7:00 p.m. to
2:00 in the morning is your gateway to
get out of the thing that you complain
about yet we'd rather watch entire
seasons of friends again on Netflix the
one thing that connects everyone here
regardless of you're winning you're
losing company employee entrepreneur the
one thing from coast-to-coast that
connects every person here is the one
asset that we should all be chasing is
attention before you achieve anything
whatever the hell you came here for when
you go an output to try to create your
business run for mayor raise money for a
non-profit no matter what you do no
matter what you try to accomplish when
you leave this conference the one thing
that you should be tape chasing is
people's attention before you can
accomplish selling a speaker or a cookie
or a t-shirt or insurance or whatever
you do you need somebody's attention to
tell them then your message has to be on
point enough to commit them into doing
what you'd like
attention my friends is the asset
nothing else is important to me besides
attention the reason I've always adapted
to new content and new platforms the
Internet itself email YouTube Google
AdWords Facebook Twitter podcasting all
of it the reason I've always done well
with that is my religion above anything
else is where is the attention today and
potentially tomorrow not what worked
yesterday
[Music]
it's crazy how I feel my whole life
never had peer pressure never did
anything anything ever ever that I
didn't want to do because just didn't
value somebody else's opinion over mine
and that comes from good parenting
circumstance DNA a million things I
don't know how to teach that what I'm
just trying to do is I'm trying to
become in a weird way I like being
popular because I become your courage I
think the most flattering thing that's
happening to me in my life is I'm
becoming people's courage because when
they take risk and they take ridicule
they point to me and then I tell their
parents to go themselves it makes the
most sense in the world to go high risk
in your youth because you can live in
your parents house you too and 19 people
watching can live in a studio 21 deep I
know it I lived it I saw it I watched it
like this is exactly when you guys are
supposed to take two core leaps of faith
either go and do it for yourself or get
close to something that you believe in
completely if you let somebody else's
opinion whether your spouse your boss
your mom your aunt your best friend if
you genuinely genuinely are living your
only life which oh by the way by modern
scientific terminology is 400 trillion
to 1 if you even could comprehend how
ridiculous it is that we are even alive
like do you understand how ludicrous it
is that you have a life
there's nothing mathematically in life
that can happen that is more ridiculous
than the fact that you've got one you're
more likely to get struck by lightning
14 times than have a life forward
forward forward mindset all of that
leads to one thing if you do not become
a practitioner of how to communicate on
the social networks of today you are
100% irrelevant don't like it tough
figure it out execute it my friends
negativity can lead at half time
kindness always wins the game
[Music]
your life is predicated on when you get
real quiet and you can't hear another
person's two cents the reason I can work
17 hours a day is because I'm not
spending 15 hours a day
dwelling or looking back faking it to
make it is the great flaw of this
generation please don't do it
please stop listening to anybody but
yourself please eliminate negativity
from your life because if you want to
really win it is absolutely by
reinforcing positivity
so get real quiet in here get real
selective about who you're spending time
with and most of all speak the truth do
the right thing kindness is cool truth
is cool don't act like you've made it
talked about the journey of trying to
make it hey guys thank you so much for
watching my video on YouTube I wanted to
jump in here at the end because I'm
working on a ridiculously important
project for me and I have a funny
feeling you can help if you drink wine
at all or know anybody that drinks wine
at all please go to empathy wines calm
right now and sign up for a subscription
whether it's a three pack whether it's a
six pack or whether it's a whole case of
each for the year if you drink 36
bottles of wine a year or give away 36
bottles of wine a year please sign up
for Club empathy this project means the
world to me that could really use your
support